can you hear me now yeah okay sorry um
so do we have any declaration of
counsellor interests
that might relate to today's agenda that
haven't been declared to this point
yes your honor i've uh you wish it while
he won
item number six i was participating
in the program itself in
some of the workings uh
no financial okay but just working on us
so
note that uh note that conflict is there
any other conflicts that need to be
declared at this point it's not okay
um we'll move on then to confirmation of
minutes
and reports and the first one do we have
is the confirmation of the minutes the
ordinary meeting our council held
tuesday 13 april would somebody like to
move that be seen as a true and correct
record
councillor phillips double seconder for
that councillor reed thank you
is there any alterations required to
that record
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
confirmation of the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of council held
20 april would somebody like to move
that that be seen as a true and correct
record
council grant seconded council dixon
thank you
is there any alteration required to that
report
the council hosted your thanks to
worship on
page nine paris six uh it quotes me as
saying the orders were the same firm
the wording i used was a bit clumsy i
said a bunch of auditors
uh the bunch being ordered new zealand i
think the firm could have issues with
that statement
so you you believe you said something
else that might have been a little bit
more defined i've checked the audio i
referred to
the bunch of auditors okay in my mind i
was referring to audit new zealand who
the
firms represent okay not the firm so the
council is
comfortable that we alter that record to
record audit new zealand okay
right are there any other operations
required
do not i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
motion is carried thank you councillors
uh urgent late business we have one item
of
tabled urgent late business and it
relates to the issuing of council
warrants
and the reason it's not on the agenda is
it
missed the deadline so our council is
comfortable that that be
considered an urgent late business in
the later parts of this meeting i'll
move in that direction anyway
second to counselor phillips thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
okay uh item five and we have before us
a petition that has been
circulating in recent times relating to
the streets alive program which has been
rolled out uh throughout the the western
part of
the gore township and we have a
a petition that has
been delivered to the chief executive
on time i understand is that right on
time
uh and is being presented by
christopher scholes um chris
do you want to make some comment or
speak to the petition please
are concerned
um
thank you
thank you chris uh for the the comments
you've made um
thank you for the effort that you've put
in to make this uh petition
available and and also thank you to
everyone that has taken
the time and the interest to to sign the
petition
um council always takes seriously
any petition or request that it receives
officially
and certainly there will be all due care
and consideration
taken with this particular one as well
uh look i think it's
it's fair to say uh that
you would be a blind man to see that
there hasn't been quite a bit of
um conversation around the town about
this
over the last little while and
we need to be very aware of
of that there's a process to work
through
and we need to take a little bit of time
to consider that
um just in terms of process
um i'm going to ask the chief executive
he if he might lie
out just what that process looks like
so that everybody in the room
understands how we work from
here yeah thanks your worship um
the process from here the petition uh
doesn't have too many legal obligations
or restrictions on the council so the
council is
predominantly free to consider the merit
of the petition
and form a view as to what it would like
to
do in response to the request being
submitted
in this particular case there is an
added dimension and that that's
the major funding partner is the new
zealand transport agency
so that would not my advice would be
that the council would need to
confer with nzta about
the petition and any proposed
course of action or view that the
council may have
in response to that petition and the
council may
also want to commission
some advice from staff before forming
that view and making the final decision
um they are the suggested ways forward
it's just the ways forward
the only i think strong moral
condition with that is the staff advice
is optional
but i do believe with 90 of the project
being funded by an external agency
that the council is duty bound to at
least confer with that agency
thank you okay councillors
uh the floor is open for your comment
and or question either of the the chief
executive
or the petitioner chris who's made the
presentation this morning councillor
heisted
i guess your worship it would be good
for the entire room just to
understand where to from here with the
trials so
what does it look like at the completion
of three months
what what's going to happen in gore when
the trial is completed
okay so i'm going to flick to peter
peter standering who's the roading
manager so peter's been
heavily involved in this program and if
you could just respond
to council heisted peter that would be
good
for your worship um this is this as
everyone will know is a year-long
project
with nceta so a good part of us to do
with
a consultation with the public and then
the rollout and then
testing and then we're wrapping up of it
all at the end so
provisions of the budget budget
provision to
to wrap everything up this is to take
all initiatives
initiatives back off the road at that
time
and consult with what we do going
forward
so yeah so um can you just clarify that
for me
when you talked about a year-long
year-long process
and i think it's generally acknowledged
that it's a three-month
trial the difference between those two
things
nzta wanted a lot of community input
into this that's why we've spent a lot
of time over the last eight months
talking to the community establishing
some strong themes about
what they would like to see in the
community developing some plans
and been my last month just rolling
things out the three months is the
time we've got left and just a
reasonable
trial period that ncta wants to see
being wrapped up in a year and a report
about the changes about
the way forward from here to permanency
i suppose for
the trials if they were to remain um but
also
just for their own learnings going
forward
okay councillors are there any other
questions council macphail then council
bulger
uh yes you worship just uh through your
worship to uh peter
um in regard to other areas obviously it
being a trial
um have we discussed issues that have
occurred in other areas
whether they've done a midpoint review
in regard to
um changes that could occur
so free worship you're talking about
here in gore or yes
with some of the other councils that
have had the um same project
uh were working for the same projects
have we had any other ones that
um we could look at where they've done a
midpoint review
and made changes like what is the
procedure
free worship of all these different
there's about 40 different projects
throughout the country
and we're all driven primarily to make
change
in active modes in our towns and cities
but they all come with different
outcomes
if you like so i haven't heard of any
who have actually had a review
this is to take it away this is usually
a project has been forced to be taken
away because they haven't had good
foundation within the community they
haven't consulted beforehand
they haven't had maintenance of their uh
installations
so there's been good reason while some
have been taken back in
but most around country do run because
okay counselor bulger
i've managed to turn the microphone on
we're good
look i've been a lot of interested in
this i've had a lot of people that cost
me and say look we're not happy with any
of this and
and a lot of discussion and i i think
i'll just repeat what i
i said to those people it is a trial
it's not
cast and stone it's not permanent uh
you're not going to wake up one morning
and find all these elements
you know permanent and concrete and
there was always going to be some
elements
probably not very many
that were going to be embraced by the
majority of people and some that just
clearly didn't work
and but bearing in mind that transit is
the driver of this project and they hold
the purse strings
they are a major funding partner to the
rest of our roading
network we are um we do have a
responsibility to to deal with them as a
partner
um are they in a position where they're
going to impose some of these things
on on council without air air um
approval
or the approval of the right partners no
i don't believe they are and the thing
that really comes out of it for me is
is transits possibly objectives are
different
than perhaps those people who live in
gore and their objectives i
i believe are that they wish to close
down and they wish to slow down traffic
and and make it more
uh pedestrian family et cetera where
some people who might live and go want
access and they want to get to work or
they want to come home as quickly as
possible
so those things are quite different i do
think there's one or two things in the
in the trial that are good
i want to turn the roundabout seem to
work for some people
that's just my opinion and look
i i guess while i'm not generally a big
fan of
petitions you know people have taken the
time and filled it in and maybe we can
put
the petition alongside the survey
analysis and it can be considered there
and used in a construction constructive
fashion
but you know i just want to reiterate
we're not going to wake up
one morning and find out that all these
things are permanent
and and um there's not going to be a
chance of change
thank you councillor bulger councillor
grant then councillor
um garden thank you worship um
yeah i'll reiterate what the fellow
councils have said
in hindsight's a marvelous thing we
possibly
should have done a little bit better
communication
the way this was rolled out um it has
all of a sudden one morning a little old
lady or a little old person or even a
young person driving down the street all
of a sudden
if they haven't been on social media and
don't read the newspapers
you'll come across a roundabout sitting
in the middle of the road
that has happened and
me being quite accessible to the public
in my business
i i've had quite a number of people
every day
coming to see me about this very very
strong opinions but as as
chief executive just said we have to
roll this out
and because we are uh have a funding
partner
i believe we should finish it to for the
three-month trial we've only got about
six weeks to go
um and i think also in the start of june
if sonia
will correct me there's another survey
coming out
in the newspaper is that right uh
through the worship yes it's the
intention is to run a second survey
um first week or so in june
yes so um that's your time again
if those people have missed out doing
the first survey
is to get in again have you have your
opinions again
your opinions may change you don't know
you've got six weeks to to use this
uh also some of the communications
regarding the the pots and the plantains
those planters are not permanent
it has been stated a number of times on
on their social media has been stated a
number of times in the newspapers
and some people haven't haven't picked
up on that but
it is a trial and i think that the
petition well done
on getting the petition going rosemary
anne and christopher we've been
um you've yeah you've you've
got a strong petition there so thanks
very much
thank you um john
yes um i represent the council on the
target south and transit committee
and just taking it a step back further
this is actually a government policy
statement coming straight from the
government to transit
to make streets more work walker
friendly and cyclists
friendly and that's where it all started
it's come from central government
so that's where you can lay the blame
but then they've
rolled out these trials all through the
country and they've spent quite a few
million dollars
and that has come out of our petrol and
road tax and probably come out of our
repairs and maintenance for transit's
budget
this trial will last only three months
and transit does
subsidise our roading and gore by used
to be 55 percent
and now it's i've moved it up to 79.
um whether that's because people have
been kind and allow them to have the
trial or not we don't really know but
we've got 59 subsea coming up next
period
we need probably do need to see the
trial out and we do need to hear from
people
whether they like this stuff or don't
like it
i've got the group here tonight not
liking it but we need to hear from the
other side and see these other
um surveys to decide what
may be done in the future all the stuff
gets taken away at the end of three
months
and as peter said and then it'll hinge
on the roading budget and the roading
team
and people's um opinions or people's
response to the any changes that they
want to done in the future
and the trial will probably stay for the
three months
thank you okay thank you
john is any other comment from
councillors
um counselor phillips thank you your
worship
it's caused some
controversy within the families and
probably
my mind as well as people know
but i just emphasize that it is a trial
and there is some things that we may
have forgotten about that
people out there might think so what
about this street have you thought about
doing something with this street
so we haven't heard from that yet so if
you've got any ideas that you might
say that safe arguments like the pomona
street
you might want it to go the other way
you don't know we don't know
so it's all about ideas bringing forward
your ideas
and i assure you as a counselor that i
listen to what people say
and we will make it make a concise
decision
that's the best for the community um
and that's all i think we can do thank
you
um councillor reed thank you your
worship
um i'd just like to mention that i think
the comment that it wasn't communicated
well is actually
um possibly a little under target
we spent a lot of time communicating and
unfortunately
it's the same old story people only get
involved when it affects them
and also um i i think that the team
already has taken notice of issues that
people have brought up and made changes
and a lot of our staff have been at the
cutting edge of personal abuse
and seeing their work basically
destroyed and i honestly think that
you know all of that aside we do need to
be
aware that while there are some
negatives and
i've got my own ideas on a couple there
have also been a lot of positives
and quite often the positives because
they are positive
nobody actually mentions them and those
people who are happy with those changes
um just roll with it they think it's
okay everybody will like it
so i think also it's just the fact
sometimes that i think
the negative becomes the big thing and
um
i'd like to see less of the negativity
and a little bit more positivity if
that's all possible
please thank you councillor um
is there any other counselors that want
to make any comment to the stage council
dixon
right i just have some concerns for
because score is has an aging population
and i know
there are a lot of elderly people that
are too scared to go out and drive in
their streets and i
i find that quite disturbing and i'm
really listening to the public
i think there's only about 20 per cent
of
these trials that people are happy with
the other 80 i think they would very
gladly do away with
and as a councillor i think we have to
listen to the rate payers
and do what's best for everybody
[Applause]
so what does that mean council it means
we have to listen to what the people are
telling us through the petition
and the survey and make the right
decision okay
um any other comments or questions from
councillors
councillor davis you think you worship
i'm just listening to everybody and i'm
pondering if everything gets taken away
at the end
i mean everything gets taken away and
yet we know for example there's a
roundabout
an eric street that's working really
well and the majority of people think
well it's good that it's there is there
no chance we can hang on to that
and i'm asking the roading transport
manager
possibly is there any way we can hang on
to that for example if there's
a couple of things that we're hearing
from the public are working
can we not just hang on to those and and
let them take everything else
free worship i probably need to be clear
that i have to have provision within my
budgets to take everything back
in if a council decide that something
is to stay out there but um it's up to
the council to decide
yeah okay and
and there's been a bit of comment made
this afternoon about
how there's good things and bad things
and and personally i have exactly the
same feelings i've got there's some
aspects of this that i really like
i like what's happened in eric street i
think it's a really good thing
and i think that we can build on that to
make something quite special in earth
street and eric street's been a
challenge for a long time and if you
talk to any of the retailers in there
you'll
you'll know that and it's interesting
talking to some of the retailers now
particularly those that serve coffee and
and what have you
just how much use that those changes are
are having
positive use the roundabouts
i really think they're good i think
they're too small but i don't know that
we can do much about that because of the
size of the intersection that they're
servicing but certainly given what was
there
previously and i'm thinking particularly
about the one by new world
uh it's it's a hundred percent better
than was there before
and and i know that it can be a
challenge uh for people of all ages not
just older people
um but younger people as well when
there's a change comes into
into being and i know the first time i
came across the roundabout
well you know i knew this was happening
but i was surprised
that it was was right there and they got
to think about it um
so we do need to be very careful about
how we drive around the streets
i'll be interested and i'll i'll just
ask um chris if i can
just in the uh when in your preamble
when you presented the petition you
talked about
a number of areas where you had concerns
and you were concerned about school
children
and um and the effect and the safety
that they had
had have you had any conversation with
schools at all
no i haven't talked to any of the
schools but i have
um observed particularly out here where
the buses go in to pick up the
saint mary's children that the bus stops
and has to give way to cars coming up
and it can be there for a few minutes
you know which builds up a
backlog behind it
so yeah there is that other safety
aspects i mean i sit at my kitchen
window
every morning and have breakfast and
watch
cars perhaps breaking the law by going
through the street the wrong way
and as far as
it's supposed to slow down the traffic
a lot of cars that are going the right
way through there are going a hell of a
lot quicker than they were
um and putting people on to pedestrians
and bikes when you have a look at it
some of the people that are riding bikes
um are actually at the moment
forced to go out into the
traffic you know like when you come up
from childhood road
you actually have to go out around the
bollard things
which should put you in the traffic of
big truck and the you know
big trucks and stuff coming up the road
i mean that is definitely
i think an accident waiting to happen
um so yeah i think
a lot of the safety things that we're
trying to
prevent or bring in are not
actually being doing what they're
supposed to yeah
and thank you for that and
i acknowledge there are some things
we've all got our personal favorites and
and favorite hates i guess in terms of
um
streets alive program and there are some
things that i don't like
and and i'm quite happy to be be open
about that i really struggle with
the the sheer number and volume of
courtesy crossings
i struggle with courtesy crossings in
fact i struggle with pedestrian
crossings full stop
on intersections but that seems to be
the the flavour that
the land transport people
accept is the safest place to put them i
can't for the life of me work out how
that
that makes some sense but courtesy
crossings right on
intersections in my mind is is not a not
a good thing
um the the pots uh i've
got some challenges with the pots i'd
have to say um
there's no doubt about that and and it's
it's been an interesting
situation just observing this this roll
out
um the pots are there so that people can
see
and feel safe and and i understand that
but what it what it has done is
really shown me how proud this community
is
of the the way our town is presented
and those pots don't fit the way this
town
is presented so i've got an issue around
courtesy crossings
and i've got an issue around pots but
that's just my personal preference
and i'm just one vote around a council
table but we've just got to work through
the issues
and there will be some good stuff come
out of this there will be some changes
and it's definitely not going to stay
the same as it as it currently is
but we we do have a time frame to work
to
and and you can bet your bottom dollar
that when council makes a decision
those changes will happen as soon as
they possibly can
can now i'm aware that not every
counselor has spoken
is there any counselors that want to
make a comment at all
council garden again i just wondered if
what people's feelings was of closing
off the end of brown street
i know the petition is against it but um
transit's idea of closing that was to
stop the heavy traffic
bypassing north so i guess we're we're
here to
consider the petition as it stands
and there are aspects in the position
that are mentioned some that
some that aren't but i think that if we
start asking
um the view of everybody in the room
their view on certain aspects then
we're going to be here all afternoon but
just even if people take that away and
think about it yeah
um so
could i just say to that that if that is
the reason why
then why don't we pass a buy law through
the council which i believe can be done
for vehicles that are over five tonne
not to be uh
use that street
yeah look it's been a been an ongoing
issue for some time
and there have been periods where
heavy transport operators have
obeyed the rules and have used the the
bypass
but there are times and i guess it's
when there's drivers change and whatever
that
that is ignored and and i know that some
of the positive comments i've had from
residents um some of the residents
particularly
near the bottom of the hill in brown
street
at the the lack of trucks that are going
up the hill now and
the lack of noise uh that that is
generating so
while a lot of people won't recognize
heavy tracks
trucks on brown street as an issue it
certainly is an issue
for some and it's certainly an issue for
the state of that road
like if you're having heavy vehicles up
and down an urban street
then it puts a lot of stress on it that
that street was never ever designed for
and in the end of the day each one of us
in the room has got to contribute to the
maintenance
of those streets so just getting trying
to get that right is the
is the balance council davis
uh through your worship the the other
aspect of
closing the end of brown street is the
speed of the vehicles that
are traveling up and down there and i
know some people that live
at towards the bottom end and they say
it's so much
safer now that it was because people
just use it as a race track
and they they come in from um
from the highway and they they put the
foot down
or up the hill or they come down the
hill and
they don't care about the speed limit
they're just 70ks
and that that's a real issue as well for
anyone living on that street
so these are things we've got to think
about
and i must add that when i talk about
getting positive comments from
residents of brown street i've had
negative comments as well
largely people that are domiciled right
down near the end
of the street um near the main road did
you want to make
no sorry did you want to make a comment
doug no okay
okay um well the two aspects today
we need to receive the petition now and
we've we've done that
and then we need to receive the survey
results
and discuss those and then make some
decisions about
where we go from here if there is
anything that
we want to alter in the short term
or are we going to go with the period of
the trial that we've
already set down so
unless there's any further questions or
comments
regarding the petition specifically
i'm going to once again thank the
petitioner
and the the people that have signed the
petition thank you for taking the
interest that you have
in your town and giving us some guidance
as to what your views are
on particular areas and
ask for somebody to move that we receive
the petition now so councillor bulger
has moved that we received the position
secondary council grant
thank you any further any comment
regarding that motion does not i'll put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye
against the motion is carried right
we'll move on to the next item which is
the survey analysis
and we have um with us this afternoon
uh rebecca mcelray who carried out
the survey and and i'm just going to ask
rebecca if she would like to to make
some comments
around the process and the results
and what some interpretation
thank you thank you your worship um
hi everybody i'm revij i have been
contracted
by council as an independent to assist
them with
the survey in relation to the streets of
life project
the survey has been developed to gauge
people's awareness
of the project and early opinions of the
project
so the methodology we've developed the
survey to test the streets of live
concepts
reflect attitudes of people and
establish the level of customer
satisfaction
for the streets of life trials that are
happening
the survey is made up of both closed and
open questions
the open questions have really given the
community an opportunity to express
their opinions for each concept
as well as in general each comment
that was received has been analyzed into
various common themes
which have been reported back through
this survey analysis
just note that some respondents have
highlighted more than one concern
or issue so your percentages won't add
up
within that report
the idea was to do an early survey and
then one when the trial has ended to see
whether or not
residents opinions have changed over
time um
whether that's positive or not um it'd
be good just to gauge that process
so really getting on to the analysis
it looked at the roundabouts the
courtesy crossings the pocket parks
and the changes in earth street so
we had 742 people respond
to the survey and
throughout the survey some or all of
them have responded to each question
with the roundabouts question we had 54
of respondents out of 738
who were positive to very positive about
the roundabouts
that 53
would like some to become permanent
of that and 27 to all of them
to become permanent
um and fairfield street and erwell and
fairfield street roundabouts were
the main roundabouts that people liked
at this stage
one of the changes the main change that
they would like to see that residents or
respondents would like to see
is that the roundabouts are small which
has already been discussed today but
they're very small to navigate around
safely
so people were concerned about that but
they were also
concerned that there was not enough
signage
to ensure that they are used correctly
going on to courtesy crossings um
65 were negative or very negative about
their experiences
and that was out of 723 respondents to
the question
um and then
66 um would not like any of them to
become permanent and 26
would like some of them to become
permanent
the main reasons for this
was that they are confusing and
dangerous
and also children not understanding the
rules a lot of people
also mentioned that they would rather
than be pedestrian crossings as people
knew how to use pedestrian crossings in
the area already
if they needed to be there at all
and then we go on to pocket parks so
out of the pocket parks there were 726
respondents describing what their
experiences were
out of this 72 were negative or very
negative
and 84 of these respondents don't want
them to become permanent
um a lot of concerns and
issues around the pocket parts are
related to
again teaching kids that they taught
kids to be on the roads as opposed to
off the roads
so it's a safety thing also that they
can just traffic
and increase traffic flow in other
streets in areas especially around the
schools and kindergartens
um so then we come on to erk street
changes
and generally um
44 of respondents were positive to very
positive
um 27 were neither positive nor negative
about this
um and then when asked if respondents
would like the earth street partners
to become permanent 53 ncts and 47 said
no
for those who said yes they
described the changes there is good for
the town culture it has a good vibrancy
in the area
it's great to be able to eat and drink
and relax outside
and it'll benefit more businesses with
having more foot traffic
along there for those that didn't like
the changes as much
they cited loss of car parking and
congestion of their irk street as it has
become a bit narrower to navigate
there were also comments um from 690
629 respondents in regards to
the survey and the streets alive project
as a whole and they really
just reinforce the common themes of what
they've already said throughout the
survey so
within the report there i have just um
put up some comments that were quite
common um
yeah so see any questions around that
thanks rebecca
thank you for the way you have presented
that um
i think it's pretty straightforward and
and i don't know that there will be too
many surprises
by the readers when they look at that
report
comments questions counselors
counseling will fail yeah just through
your worship for rebecca
um just confirming because i know that a
number of uh
people have asked regarding the
information that's going in
do we need to and i'm pretty sure it may
be on the website too but confirm
resubmission in regard to the ongoing
from here
if we go forward with no change to make
sure do people need to resubmit
what yes it would be good once we do the
next survey because what we're trying to
do is gauge people's opinions so
for those that haven't actually um
contributed to the survey gives him a
chance to do but it also gives those
people a chance to
either reinforce what they've already
stated or maybe
say oh actually that was quite good or
actually i'm not liking that part of the
of the trial
um so i think i'm going to change my
opinion here
the reason i sort of reaffirm that your
worship is that
obviously counselor grant sort of
indicated that some people's opinion
change over a period of months to
certain
matters that have happened it may either
improve or it may get worse
i think it's important for the community
to make sure that they are
putting those in so that if there is an
issue there it definitely is removed and
we're not um
having a sort of a midway point of
analysis that doesn't carry on right
through to the end
so we may have a differing amount of
information at the end of the trial
i take the point you're making um and in
terms of consistency that
that is right i guess i'm also taking on
board
both the petition and the results of the
of the survey and in my feeling at this
point is that
as a elected body we need to be engaging
with nzta
as as soon as we possibly can just to
talk about
the findings that have come from the
survey the feelings of the petitioners
and the ability or inability whatever it
might be
to to alter and modify or modify
various aspects of the trial going
forward
i'm not sure how that would affect
ongoing
surveys and in terms of results but
like i think you know we it behooves us
uh to take notice of what we've heard
both from the survey and from the
petition
council mcfarland
you worship um it just probably relates
to that midpoint
matter i queried from peter earlier
whether there is certain adjustments
that could be made
at that midpoint if it was
slight variances or requirements that
were needed
there may be an appetite with the
council to consider some of the
ratepayers concerns
um that we could actually do that okay
do you want to make a comment to that
peter
um for your worship just to try to be
true to the
trial i suppose there's uh you need that
consistency between the first and the
second but having said that if
there's alterations modifications that
we can
carry out that can explain the
installation better
um definitely we need to be looking at
that
counselor heisted do you have a comment
yeah thanks your worship yeah just
picking up on your
point it's pretty compelling when you
look at the petition
and the survey around these street
closures and i do wonder that
the distraction that that may have in
terms of the positive aspects of streets
of life
whether that conversation with transit
or nta
should actually explore that but by by
removing it seems to me by removing the
street closures now
we may actually get a far better feeling
from the community
on the balance of the projects
and yeah and that's one of the things we
need to canvas with with nzta
um are there any uh council phillips
you think of your worship well parts of
it has tested our community
um the question has to be is it value
for money and i believe it has been you
know we
we've got to remember that we're doing a
trial period here and
ngti are coming up with the funds
for probably future proofing and
planning what we might think might be a
good idea for the rest of our community
uh some of it yes we definitely need to
have some serious discussions with the
nzta
and one of them is broughton street and
eagle street corners off state highway
one
and it would be uh great to have ngta
and its associates around the table
have a workshop and thresh it out and
say look can we
change uh not the shutting off of brown
street but perhaps having
an out and a turnaround bay for the
people that live between
broughton street and kitchener street so
they can physically
just turn the corner there instead of
going all the way down to john road
which is a really dangerous corner in
the best of times
those sort of scenarios that we need to
get around the table and have a
discussion with
and i would like to think that nzta
would come to the party and have a trial
change
there because it's that's what they want
they want this as a trial now bear in
mind that
we're not the only ones in southland
very shortly in sunday
in the cable city we'll be trialling
there so
yeah so watch the space
that's right
councillor grant yeah you worship a sort
of um
now i i disagree with with councillor
phillips a little bit because
uh this is their decision it's not
nzta they haven't forced it on us but
they've said there's the trial
so a year ago they came to the staff and
they said we've got nine hundred
thousand dollars to give to you
uh it's for the beautification of
streets it's for the
the idea of street furniture we this is
this is the story that
if correct me if i'm wrong but this is
the story that we were told
also it's for getting people out of cars
and it's it's
for getting safely students across the
roads and everything like that
and we we wholeheartedly agree with it
then um we've had workshops now
what what the public has seen so far
is not the first draft we the actual
initial streets were blocked off
were kitchenette street anzac street
pomona street were completely blocked
off
they were they were dead ends we said
tell you on this this is not going to
run
so we got those changed but
if if we have to sit back around the
table again
and have another go at transit and say
can we do this that's that's not what
we're about we will be
i believe we should be saying this is
what we're going to do
at the end of the day it's it's the
right power of gore and this is why
we've done this survey
and an independent server that's been
done really really well
i had people come into my store
and they were very worried about the
surveys that they were handing across
the counter
because they said well who knows if it's
not you know that we might read it and
chuck it in the bin
and i said no no hang on a minute this
this is not the way the gorgeous
council operate and i've tried to tell
people that and some of them
were were a little bit um dubious
about the survey it's come out
the survey has done rebecca done a great
job of the survey
uh and it is extremely compelling i mean
54
of people are positive about the
roundabouts you know uh the pocket parks
84
of them none want them that is hugely
and it lines up with the petition
exactly so it most of 98
of this is common sense so what we yeah
i don't
believe we should be transit is a huge
part of
their um their partner and
they we do a lot of work with them but
they've given us the trial
let the trial do it and then we tell
them what this is what's going to happen
look um council boulder
i think for me and you know i'm not an
urban person i don't live in gore and so
obviously it'll be urban councils that
have the
biggest input on behalf of the people
they represent but
for me the streets alive thing has
highlighted one one street that transit
hasn't done anything about
and when this is over and when we get a
chance to talk to them
again i'd like to know you know have
they got any plans for charlton road
southwest street
you know and that's been a positive
thing albeit in the background that's
come out of this process
yep and look just just on that point i'm
i'm very aware that there are two
intersections on any state highway that
goes through the town
that are critical and and need to be
addressed one is the charlton road
self-esteem connection it's it's a it's
a
disaster waiting to happen uh and the
other one is the
entrance into hamilton park there's a
real challenge over there so we've we've
got to get those two sorted out they are
state highways
so they're directly out of our control
but we have some influence into those um
in terms of working with nzta i'm very
much
in favor of working with people rather
than dictating and just telling them
what we're going to do because
we have to work with them tomorrow not
just today tomorrow and next year
and and we've already heard just um what
what a good deal we are getting compared
to some of their compatriots and
councils up and down the country in
terms of funding so i don't want to
throw the
baby out with the bathwater but
certainly the people that sit around
this table
today have the majority influence in
what happens going forward
but i really want to engage with the
nzta
and and we've heard about transit the
nzta
transit went out of existence probably
12 years ago was it something like that
so transit's not around
but it takes us a wee while to change
their language in new zealand
transport authority which is now waka
katowi so i'm struggling with that one
but we've just got to keep on updating
our language i guess
so just remind councillors about that
but i think we need to engage with them
as soon as possible
just show them the results they'll be
very aware i'm sure of these results but
we need to discuss with them
what they see the options going forward
and we need to give our views about
where we see there might be some
alterations and modifications
made to the to the trial
and then i think we'll both get some
value out of this
are there any other questions or
comments that counsellors have counselor
read
thank you your worship um just one other
issue with the
um the streets live program
we've all been talking about the roading
and um you know the issues that
obviously are causing conflict there but
i think one of the other
positive things that have come out so
far is actually the artwork around town
which is really cool and that's a plus
for our community
um and i'd like to um just make sure
that people don't forget about those
things that
um have enhanced the town and um
and if people just reassured that moving
forward
we will do the best that we can to just
keep continuing to make it
a positive experience when they come to
gore whether they live here or whether
they come from
the district to shop here that's right
okay before we move to our
to motion um gbc
do you want to make any comment about
process um the suggestion i have of
meeting urgency with nzta
yes your worship uh look i think that's
the way to go is to
meet with ncta it's not about submission
it's about persuasion
so we're not submitting to ngta we're
trying to persuade them
i think there's some really good points
that have been raised by
uh the petitioners and the councillors
one of the things that's troubled me in
recent weeks is that particularly the
plans
don't actually resemble what would be on
the ground
if the trial was implemented so the idea
was
bulbous curbed to 150 millimeters high
and we've got planted 600 millimeters
high
so the other type of points you can
taking on board the sentiment of the
survey and the submit and
the petitioners you can bring forward to
ngta and say
look this clearly is not that part of
the trial
is not really a fair representation of
what the future might hold
therefore my view would be try and
convince them to cease that forthwith
unless there's some
other safety reasons that i'm not that
i'm not aware of
the other thing the thing about streets
closures
is potentially there's again a good
point to argue that
if there is to be a second survey at the
end of the trial
maybe uplifting some of those streets
that have been closed
would enable the public to be informed
about they have a chance to look at
both a closed street and then a reopen
street
at the end of the process and to see
whether there's any change in public
mood
um with those changes so the other type
of things i think we can bring forward
to entertain worship
and to in the spirit of the petitioners
to get some
changes made before the trial's end
via agreement rather than dictate
okay look unless there's any further
comment for
from councillors um i'm going to call
for a motion on this
um and and i'm happy to move that if
you wish me to from the from the chair
um
well i'll move uh that with urgency
council meet with
ncta to
discuss and consider
both the petition the questions raised
in the petition
the statements raised in the petition
and also the questions and comments
raised
in the survey and
yeah and what and consider the options
that might come
from that for us going forward
so it's a bit wordy but we need to meet
with them sooner rather than later
and um we need to uh
consider that as a council and that's
for this for the elected members as well
as the staff
yeah no good point yeah so yeah and the
comment that
just been made to me that um the
discussion would be
um viewed so that would be designed so
that
changes would be implemented before the
trial ended
and that was always my intention
councillor okay thank you
so the motion's been moved and seconded
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um and again i thank petitioners
uh for their interest in this uh you're
more than welcome to stay for the rest
of the council proceedings we've got a
number of items on the agenda
but if you wish to to move on
i completely understand
okay we'll move on to item seven
which is matera water safety
plan update and we've got an update from
uh
our three wooders asset manager um matt
mobilis do you want to make comment to
this
thank you worship yes so um
water safety plans is something that
we've had in place in varying degrees
for about
14 years now for our water schemes
and following the headlock north
outbreak in the inquiry and to that
the ministry of health redeveloped the
sort of safety you
the water safety plan framework um
and and it's now expected that water
suppliers will update
their water safety plans um to align
with
with that um as they come up for their
five yearly update
uh so the matara water safety plan is
due for its update
um on 1 july 2021
so we embarked on up updating that and
aligning it with the framework
late last year as we've got into that
process
it's become apparent that that
it's a significant undertaking to do
that um
and i guess it's it's dawned on us that
with the proposed
reforms um around the three water
service delivery
a lot of the work that we need to do to
update the safety plan will
fairly quickly become redundant
particularly as it it relates
predominantly around
the service provider and how they will
respond to emergencies and things like
that
um i guess the other point that i'd
highlight is that
that the water safety plan is only a
first step
in in making sure that the water being
delivered is safe
there's the safety plan identifies a
number of improvement items
that that has proposed to
to be progressed over the life of that
plan
so as we have a a water safety plan
already in place we do have an
improvement plan that we're
working towards um and some of the more
significant
um measures identified in that
other obviously the upgrading of the
material treatment plant
to to meet the requirements of the
drinking water standards which we're
taking steps to
to upgrade to
so i guess given the challenges and the
resources it's going to take to update
the water safety plan
we thought it's worthwhile getting some
direction from the council around some
options
of updating those water safety plans and
you'll see
those three options presented in the
report
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you matt the report's open
for comment and or and or question
serenity councillors want to make a
comment at this point councillor heisted
thank you so much so matt you haven't
made a recommendation
to council um are you prepared to
give us any guidance in terms of what
you recommend and i guess i just wonder
what's changed since june 2016 like
everyone wants to make sure the
community is safe
and i'm sure that staff have always
operated in that manner
is a review gonna uncover
major deficiencies that that the staff
aren't already addressing
um on an ongoing basis and if so
why would we engage a external
consultant
to to guide us
yeah thank you councillor hosted yes so
i guess fundamentally
um there hasn't been anything that
significantly changed in the
matara water supply um and the safety
of of that water being provided um
obviously the scheme's been there for
for some time now um
and yeah i guess
um
developing a safety plan won't
necessarily make the
developing a new water safety plan won't
necessarily make the scheme
safer it's the actions that that plan
will identify that will that will make
the
scheme safer and
and we have i guess done that back in
2016.
so
potentially i think that the best course
of action would be to
focus our efforts and resources on
continuing to implement that existing
safety plan and addressing some of the
improvement items that were previously
identified
with a view that um in two to three
years time
that the water safety plan would be
updated to align with the new framework
i guess i would add to that and that the
the industry in general is still
learning and
developing templates around this new
framework
so in two to three years time
[Music]
where you can potentially piggyback off
some of that work and and
take some lessons learnt from other
councils when we we do update our water
safety plan
i guess i would with that approach um
i would just highlight that we will
we won't be compliant with the
requirements under the
health act for that time so i guess
my thoughts on my comments are that the
timing of this is
unfortunate given the tomato roi
and the whole water reform process
that's being undertaken
and and i guess the question i ask of
you matt is
if something goes wrong and we're not
compliant
what then
um i might hand that question to ramesh
if that's all right
thank you worship it's a very good
question i think
the way we have framed up our long term
plan and the infrastructure strategy
we have allowed a significant upgrade to
the existing material water plant to
meet the protozoa compliance
so in my view we are doing a step up
into the existing facility
so we're already doing it we are already
doing it
it's only the paperwork which is
required to demonstrate the water safety
plan
requires it to the transformed into the
new framework
since the industry is learning and lot
of templates are getting developed
we don't want to become spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars
developing those paperwork which is
going to remain in the self
we want to do the real thing to make
sure the water is safe to the community
i think in my suggestion i think i am
courageous enough to recommend option
two
the element of risk remaining is minimum
so that
as the water services bill comes to
implementation
in first july we can consult with the
tomat which is a new regulator
and keep consulting with them ask them
there giving us a guide as being a small
council and small community
not to spend too much of money we can
learn from somebody else's
learnings out of this and rather do the
right thing to build the right
facility for the community to treat safe
water and supply it
okay that's my view okay thank you
thanks matt and thanks
ramesh uh council bulger then council
grant
yeah i think option two
or or even option three but certainly
option two
because the key word in there is review
our present water safety plan so it's
not as if we're doing nothing
and there's already some you know nuts
and bolts work being done
otherwise we're spending you know forty
seven thousand dollars on on
you know a paper exercise an exercise in
compliance and
to be honest i don't think that's the
best use of that money okay
right um doug i was just going to say
basically
mr uh counselor bulger said so um i'll
move a motion that we
go with option two okay secondary
council davis thank you
is there any further comment required
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against emotions carried right we're on
to
building control fees and we've got a
report from the building control manager
russell patterson
um russell do you want to talk us
through this please
yeah thanks
there's a bit of background i think most
of you around the table will
remember how we used to do an annual
review of fees
which was what i did in the first
probably
10 years of being at council would
review them annually and do a slight
tinker of what fees that we felt needed
to rise to cover
operational costs um in my paper there
it's it's reported
and um we haven't made any substantial
changes since 2017
um and as i've pointed out there there's
a couple of main reasons for that
and that was the southern shared forum
um for the four
southern councils were going to try and
introduce some common
fees across all four councils um there
was some spade work done for that but
nothing's
actually eventuated and each of those
four councils operate on
on different models if you like of
ratepayer input and
they've got different variables for
travel for
vehicle costings all that sort of thing
length of travel
so it was it's sort of been shelved to
some degree
and the other main reason was in may
june this time
last year after effects are covered and
after the fix of
the february flooding in our district
i did prepare a revised fee schedule and
at that time
the chief executive felt it was a good
idea to shelve it and um
just help out the community in that sort
of uncertain time
so yeah i've really put together
based on comparisons to other councils
um
about some of the fees that are quite
common
and i've put it all there in black and
white
and you'll see in the um the attached
table
anything in red print there's any new
any new fee
categories or any writing a few
categories i've
pulled out of there to save a bit of
duplication if you like
to spread some of those dollar values
and
so that's really the proposal on on the
way forward for this coming year as
as as we need to to make um department
viable
and cover costs we're we're not
competing against anybody that's the
thing we've got to remember
what we're doing is covering costs for
the service provided so
it's not like a private enterprise yeah
happy to take any questions
so um you see this becoming an annual
exercise again
um through your worship yeah possibly if
there's anything
especially after the first year to
reevaluate and say well actually
something needs altered um we hadn't
considered something or other
um it's an uncertain time because we're
going into that
electronic processing error which we're
hoping to get
into by the end of july so there's a
whole
heap of things involved with that with
some scanning
hard copy consents that happen to come
in through the door and all those things
that we've
affected into here but we don't know the
actual um
outcome of that until we start seeing
some of that take place
right thank you um council garden
you just just comment russell was um
through you
you know tracy just on those new fees
have you got the old the old figures for
the past few fees beside that you
haven't looked in there
where were you increasing where are we
going from and sorry in the left-hand
column the 2019-20
they are the current fees that have been
that way since 2017
and all the ones in yellow are the
proposed fees for
the coming year right yep
okay so council reed then councillor
dixon thank you
thank you worship thank you russell for
the report it was a good report and i
completely understand the need for user
pays
the only query i do have is about the
solid fuel heater
the increase here it's quite a bit it's
another hundred dollars per unit
and it's actually going to be the
highest across all the councils
and i would is that one of our more
um popular consents that has to be
put forward uh it is one of the
one of the most frequent um but i have
to actually
point out that it's probably one of the
most frequent one we have to
request further information on and also
at inspection time
um probably over 50 of them we've got to
revisit
so here's why there's generally two
inspections so yeah well that wasn't
stated there so
yeah i can appreciate that okay thank
you
so a reasonably small item but high
personal input
very much so yeah
um three-year worship i was just
wondering um
i saw if there's if there is a chance
that they could re-evaluate the common
fee
because i know that people find it very
confusing when
south and district have one fee and
invercargill another and grow another
and they don't compare with each other
i guess that's a possibility through
your worship as i said it had been
looked at
in previous years nothing's progressed
and i think the
parties around the table at that time
have
moved on in some degrees but yeah it
could be it could be re-evaluated
you'll note some of the fees there in
that comparison table
um some of them are last year's fees for
kluther and invercargill
and the proposed column on the
right-hand side for south and district
are
tongue-in-cheek proposed i believe they
go into the council too for quite a
major
fan crease um so if you take the kluther
and invercargill ones aside
that's still the current fees with no
proposed increase that i'm aware of but
yeah okay council bulger then councillor
heisted
well it's it's attractive to have a
common fee across the region
very difficult to do and we're looking
at a um
rating mechanism review and that would
change that again so
i think to have our own in-house
evaluation of free structures where we
go to land for the foreseeable future
right okay okay okay so
another comment or question um
if there's not uh i'm assuming
that the recommendation is favorable if
that's the case would somebody like to
be adopted
move counts to high state second to
councillor reed thank you
no further discussion all those in favor
please say hi
all right against the motions carried
thank you
right we'll move on then to item nine
and we've got another petition
uh before us and we have a petition from
some residents in
mountain road uh around the
the safety um particularly of the
of the mountain road um uh
yeah the mountain mountain road that
faces uh this area
um so we've also got a request from
robert young one of the petitioners just
to speak to council
so so robert um if you'd like to make
any comments you have now
feel free
um yeah robert young on 986 mountain
road
um to give you guys a little bit of
background mountain road um
it's about 12 13 k's of windy gravel
road with a little bit of seal at the
end of it
we've got about 24 houses on it and
growing rapidly with more development
there's a couple of small pieces of seal
at the center of the road
and then it's a number of farming
businesses on the road as well
plus it's a really popular road for
mountain bikers
runners walkers horses it's a busy
little road for gravel or little gravel
road
we we moved to do the petition because
of the whole road not just
trying to get a load of extra seal
we do we do really feel that adding
joining up the two bits of current seal
would make a big difference
um and the particularly the people who
have moved into the subdivision
over the last few years expected that
when they bought
their properties because at that stage
the developer was going to be paying a
part of it
so they'd be quite keen to know why that
was never done in the first place
but quite aside from that it's the whole
road that's an issue
it's narrow windy it's dangerous it's
all about safety really
um we've got a lot of um
narrow narrow corners and blind vises
we've got the rogenero where the water
table hasn't been maintained well
so you can't pull to the side of the
road because you just fall into a hull
we have a problem with the vegetation
not being controlled on the motor and as
a result that makes the road narrower
again
we have the problem with potholes and
corrugations because we
see a grader occasionally and with these
potholes and corrugations it changes how
people travel on the road
which then makes those blind causes and
corners and rises
even more dangerous so really
we'd love to have that extra 700 metres
of seal and we think it would be
might enhance the safety of the road a
lot but
on top of that we actually need the road
to be wider in places we'll
make it safe we need the vegetation to
be controlled so that we can actually
use all the road
and we need
much more regular grading just so that
we don't
so it keeps the road safe because we've
just had guts full of it
we've had me various ones on the road
ahead meetings with both the current
voting manager and previous rating
managers
and we get promises made but very little
happens
um and we just feel like we've been
folded off by the council and really
wonder
is somebody going to get seriously hurt
or die on this road before you actually
take any notice
that's why we'll put the petition to you
thank you okay oh
thank you robert and um forgiving me my
understanding was that the main concern
was the the steep area at this end of
the road
but i take the point that you are going
for the whole road
we we don't work the whole road sealed
no no um
but yes the piece between the divots two
inches of seals
does need sealed but also the width of
even the seal that there's
is there now is not enough at times
because the grass has been allowed to
grow another flood
come across onto it the only reason it's
not as bad as it could be is because
some of the residents of the road
actually get out there and mow it
not because the council's maintained it
but
the rest of the road is a problem as
well in dangerous spots
and we realize that ceiling's not going
to happen overnight
and i sort of worry that we're going to
get put in the box to get sealed
down the track at some stage and the
current issues are going to be forgotten
about
even if the ceiling doesn't happen
immediately we still need some [ __ ] done
okay look i hear what you're saying um
okay councillors
um look open for question
or comment to the petitioner
through your worship i concur with what
mr young is saying because i have been
up that road and
observed how dangerous it can be
and i think although there are other
roads probably in the gall district that
need attention as well
that is one that i think because of the
tightness of the road and the corners
that it it actually does need some work
done on it to make it safe
councilman oh yes i've been up
the road and spoke and had peter
standings come up there and look at the
road
particularly at this end of the road
where the new subdivision
is and it's there's certainly uh so
some issues up there with the woods of
the road
uh and some of the corners at the start
because
there is a high traffic volume there and
peter would agree the day we stood there
at nine o'clock in the morning there was
probably 20 cars past us in 10 minutes
so
there is a high usage of that road
and particularly with bigger machinery
going down the road
uh forces people off the road and
there is an ever increasing number of
residents going up there
to live and we should be seriously
looking at doing some improvements
to the road okay
accounts the guideline yeah i'd agree
the um
probably the gravel roads have been
forgotten about for the last three
three months and i think the grader
hasn't been up north of gore
for much of that and i was asking peter
the this before the meeting
why that has happened and he hasn't
given me an answer yet but
i've had complaints from residents and
other gravel roads but
that road is does need upgraded and we
do have extra
in our budget for this coming year and i
think we should consider
doing that but there is other areas too
um yeah i'd like an answer from the
radio manager why the grader hasn't been
around on a regular basis this past
summer
so um
okay thanks neil um so peter do you just
want to make any comments to the
there's a questions
for your worship i know that we um
through our contractual arrangement with
uh falten hogan and nk2 we do have
a regular grading of the road that
routine
has been sort of maintained over the
last probably
the last four years um particularly why
this road hasn't been graded i
i i can't tell you or how often it has
been i can have to talk to my
operational
manager to sort of see what's happened
there
i know that parts of mountain road um
they do suffer from
a steepness and that's probably why some
of the seal has been put in the past we
call it traction seal
so we're not all who don't have to be
even grading every six weeks or whenever
just to to give
the rights and the corrugations out so
once again that was why the traction
still was put in there because of a
train
um as far as the rest of the network
goes i know that we do have a routine
there
a few if there's particular areas that
you're concerned they haven't been
graded recently
and if i can know them i'll make sure to
look them up and see what the story is
great
thanks your worship i'll see the the
recommendation here is um
well part of the recommendation is that
the petition from a mountain road
residents be considered as a sub
it was a submission to the council's
long-term plan which closes that
submission closes next
wednesday the 19th um
steve can you elaborate a little bit on
that would you like to deliver
yeah through your worship i made that
recommendation because
i thought the council might want to just
consider this request in line with
any other request that may come through
the ltp submission process
nothing if you agree with that approach
nothing further needs to
occur uh you have my report
the analysis uh and
what is substantively a positive
recommendation but that goes into the
mix of other priorities that you may
be asked to consider through the
submission process and you've got to
obviously
figure out what what you can afford and
what you cannot afford and
council guidelines raised a very good
point with the increase in the
nzta subsidy that cuts it on one july
and the council's
information that it will not change its
local share and expenditure there is
there is a
an element of finance there that's
available for roading enhancements
but that was my suggestion but
the council if it chooses to can make an
alternative
decision tonight
council read then council phillips thank
you your worship
and just a quick question for peter if i
might um
what's the criteria for further traction
function uh
sorry for further traction sealing on
that piece of
the incline that's not already sealed
between the two sealed pieces
for your worship uh there requires to be
a criteria around that
whether we in a cell extension or even
attraction seal
at the moment there's nothing formally
developed in that way but it would be
questions around safety it would be
about around about dust to
be re the cost of maintenance
but be uh probably the main factors they
would take into consideration probably
proximity of power system road
so be a number of criteria that you
you'd put in that
so would that if what if that criteria
was met
we would meet that and for the
nzta funding
free uh worship there's a criteria that
we haven't put in place at the moment
so there's a couple of items here we
need to have a
willingness to do these seals whether
it's seal extension or retraction seal
and then there's the other item of what
we can put it underneath what activity
we can
achieve this through ncta funding so
it's not
quite straight line we do have to sort
of see that matches up with one of your
activity classes
thank you councillor phillips thank you
your wish
just right in part of the report you
have some examples of
further ceiling in the network uh it
concerns me about
um i'll take one example don't worry
park road which
i just about got wiped out the other day
by a logging truck coming down that road
and these are things that concern me for
the future if
if we start not looking after your roads
properly that
and i'm not sure why there's a logging
truck using the gravel road
between um
coming down domwall park road in the
first place where there's a sealed road
that goes down into state highway 94
but i think we probably need to have a
bit of a review on
and some of these roads that are on this
list and
make a
a decision about what what the priority
might be
for the future not only for what um
the land use is going to be uh it could
be for residential
etc so you know okay so um
counselor heist did then um as everybody
else wants to speak
counselor bulger
you thank you russia i guess i'm
comfortable with the recommendation that
it goes forward to the long term plan
but
i guess the report's very focused on
sale extension whereas mr young's
um saying hey there's more issues on
that road so
provided that long-term plan
is sorry the submission process is
supported by further report
perhaps from the staff on the whole of
road issue
so that we are in a position to to
consider the whole picture
um i believe that is the most
appropriate way forward
yeah and it's it was good to hear that
explanation from robert tonight because
my
my understanding was that the prime
concern was the the beginning of the
road from this
end um but it appears not to be
um and uh we need to look at the whole
thing so there'll be some maintenance
issues in there
um but there may well be some some
upgrading that's required in other parts
of that road council bulger
uh he's very comfortable for it to go
through the
long-term plan process we've heard a
description of the problems on mountain
road we now
need a response on the roading manager
how it would be funded
the scope of the work and the various
areas where their monies might come from
and
then we can make a decision obviously
something needs to be done though
it's the degree to what can be done over
what period of time
yep and look there's no doubt that
there's a lot more building and
vehicles using that road than it's ever
been before
um so so we do need to treat this
seriously
counseling fail yes
thank you rob for coming in and
presenting that to
the council here um obviously support uh
support what has been discussed so far
um and particularly around that
obviously vegetation control
and the other aspects that need to go in
for the full package
so that we're not only doing half a job
the second
thing is in regard to obviously through
your worship to peter
in relation to graders obviously grade
is going down the road but prior to that
we have reviews
we obviously have a roading review teams
or k2 goes around the
the gravel roads assessing them um would
we be able to find out
the how regular this is occurring
because
it's obviously a common uh for us that
live in the
areas with with the gravel roads it's a
common um
query from ratepayers in regard to the
last time the review team had been
through
checking your road so i suggested
perhaps for um
our next meeting or an update on how
regularly that happens and what the
contracts required
like what they've required to provide to
us
thank you
okay if there's not any further
questions is
is the recommendation that's before you
and
the right recommendation was
somebody like to move that
recommendation if they believe that it's
the right direction for us to go
to get this issue sorted council may
fail a seconder for that
council uh bulger thank you
is there any further questions or
comments
council davis um just so long as
councillor hosted's
suggestion is is incorporated in that
motion that's
a further report from the roading
managers oh yes
on the whole of road solution yeah
yeah look i think we're we're certainly
aware now that it's not just a
one section of the road it's the whole
road that needs to be be
considered okay with that in mind
uh i'll put that emotional those in
favor please say aye against the motion
is carried thank you councillors
and in terms of the petitioners
um certainly this will be
is there any need to submit to the
long-term plan
for any further need for them to do that
uh know your worship and uh but
obviously
uh as a submission the submitter has a
right to be heard if
the submitters want to come again
and they may well want to in relation to
the covering report that roadie staff
will prepare
although i'm not sure whether we'll
prepare
by submission closure i'm thinking out
loud here um
it's more likely that where our report
on this matter will
go to the deliberative meeting of the
council in june
so really i'm probably answering my own
question or statement here but
you probably don't need to come again uh
until the deliberative meeting
when the council actually sits uh sits
down
and works out what are those decisions
on the respective submissions received
at that point in time um you may want to
liaise all the spokes personally as with
worship and
and even potentially request speaking
rights uh as you've
you won't be going to the hearing i
wouldn't imagine but you've been wanting
to perhaps
comment on the report that the council
staff will provide the council
to enable it to make a decision and that
will be in the latter half of june
thank you that said the hearing process
is an open process so
should you wish to be part of that than
you can be as well
right we'll move on then to
item 10 which is a report on
the surplus or potential surplus
property subcommittee
thank you everyone uh and
we have you've done the report there
steve right
so we've got a report um from the chief
executive do you want to speak to that
um yes you wish this the first meeting
of the property sub
potential property disposal sorry
potential
surplus property subcommittee we'll have
to find a new name i think i think i had
an informal name in the um terms of
reference
um the me i can report that uh from an
officer point of view it was a really
good meeting
uh some parts of these minutes are
actually in the public excluded portion
of
the agenda but this will be the first of
what i suspect will be quite a number of
meetings
as the committee
warms to it to its task um
and the first meeting was focused a lot
around
the methodology around how to prioritize
the workload
identify where some of the
potentially quick hits can be achieved
and so already in the last
two or three weeks the committee has met
twice and is establishing some good
momentum
okay um just just a question and
i'm being pedantic here i guess but i
see we're talking about a report rather
than minutes
or um should that be
minutes or a report
like a normal normal way we go about
things is
if there's a formal meeting it's minutes
that we receive isn't it
yes you worship uh it's a subcommittee
and by nate
by its very nature it tends to be less
formal
and a little more unstructured in its
discussion
and debate than what you'd normally
receive at a committee or a council
meeting
but for completeness minutes are what is
recognized
in the both the local government
official
information and meetings act and the
local government actually it should be
minutes of a meeting and we have
somebody taking minutes yes yes so
i think we we should be correct and and
just note that change
okay so look open for discussion is
there any um
any question um comment
just a quick one it wasn't it was a very
quick medium but it didn't take one
minute
that's good it's a lot of stuff um
it was actually the next meeting was in
may the 5th at 5 15
and the meeting concluded at probably
607.
right so the recommendation is that the
minutes be received and the
recommendations contained within the
report be ratified
so we'd like to move that way councillor
davis dove signature council grant
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
right um again is it
reported minutes of the community board
okay yeah
okay so move on to item 11 and again um
we'll just
change that terminology from report to
minutes and
we have a recommendation or two
recommendations
required one that they must be received
and that they be
ratified so um
somebody like to speak to this and um
either move or
change so move counselor philip seconded
counselor guarding that the minutes be
received
and uh report ratified okay all those in
favor please say aye
against emotions carried
right we'll move on then to item 12
which is the financial report to the
31st of march
and we've got a memo here from chief
financial officer
thank you lornae and i'll ask you now if
you would
just like to work us through that and
answer any questions that counselors
must have
i'm matera
didn't we just do that
yeah we've done that um
yeah it's all right just to keep up
um right lorna thank you your worship
um i'll take the report largely as read
but some key points to note and
which is continuing theme for this
financial year is that
our financial results are being masked
by the stimulus funding we've been
receiving from government so our revenue
is
2.18138 million favorable this
is made up of 1.35 for stimulus funding
for three waters
500 thousand dollars for closing the
gaps or mass tasks for jobs
so we we have been very lucky recipients
of some government funding to help the
community
and we're very appreciative of that
these will end up being net
um have net effect on our financials or
just be a timing difference between
now and some of it falling into next
year um
our expenditure again this is this is
slightly over
some of it has contributed towards um
some of the funding
or some of their activities going on
such as the multi-sports centre
re-roofing
again we received funding for this and
it will turn out to be a
neutral cost neutral um activity
um wastewater maintenance with a
scenario where we've had to spend
additional funds this year
um particularly around the the odors and
the ponds
so funding has been
moved from one area and water to another
to cover this
and again it's full of waste levees
which we have discussed at previous
previous council meetings
so happy to answer questions questions
comments counselor hosted
your thanks through your worship if if
we stripple it out one day and just get
back to our operational funding without
stimulus
how are we looking are we are we close
to budget or not
through your worship um yes councillor
heisted we are tracking just slightly
behind budget about 20 000
unfavorable for the year to date
council macphail it's just uh
really just a common uh comment to our
financial officer obviously the work
that she's putting in
uh credit to the work that she's put
into the uh ltp
um i think it needs to be recognised in
the effort that there
particularly i think it was a role that
she's done for the first time so
well done
absolutely okay
there's no other commental question
would somebody like to move that the
report be received
councillor reid thank you double
secondary councillor
dixon thank you all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried okay
i think that no we've got an urgent late
by them haven't we
we'll do this down yes yeah okay so as
noted at the beginning of the meeting
we have one urgent late my item that's
been tabled
and hopefully councils have got a copy
of that before them
and it's regarding warrants for staff
so i think it was in the heart was not
yeah just in the hub
so i'll just give you a minute to find
that
what's in mine
that's right
okay uh who's going to lead this this is
you as us steve yeah thank you worship
um this is directly a tribute
attributable
to having new staff occupy
positions where there potentially can be
some enforcement
needed and one of the peculiarities
of the local government act is that
the warranting of enforcement officers
is a the sole preserve of
the council there's no provision for
delegation
therefore we need to have your approval
to have these new offices
in positions specified in the port
warranted as
enforcement officers this doesn't mean
that we're going to be going out there
with gay abandon to flex regulatory
muscle
but it just means that if we do have to
exercise some enforcement
we have the legal backing courtesy of
your authorisation to do so
okay question council bulger no question
i'll move the recommendation
council appointment authorised the
aforementioned staff members
have a sector for that uh councillor
davis thank you
uh is there any comments this night i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried okay look
i think that
brings us to the end of the open agenda
we do have some items
to be discussed in committee so i'll
move
that um